I don't find you masculine so the
feeling is mutual my point but you have
the mentality on of these social media
men like the men on social media who
have so much to say internet Warriors
like they've got so much to say about
what a woman should do how a woman
should dress how women should look
you're not feminine like oh like yeah
there are women that are not feminine
women like this is the real world yeah
and they die alone okay they don't get a
pig women outlive men anyways and with
why would you want it's not a
competition I'm not saying it is but
statistically women outlive men so
what's your plan my point is that it's
not it's not misogyny
like you have misogyny you have
misogynistic views yes
you know for free and that's coming from
a woman
[Music]